what do you do you're not an engineer
you're not a designer you can't put a
hammer to a nail I built the circuit
board the graphical interface was stolen
so how come 10 times in a day I read
Steve Jobs as a genius what do you do
musicians play their instruments I play
the orchestra
here you've been worse than usual this
morning I didn't think that was possible
it's a system error fix it fix it yeah
we're not a pit crew at Daytona this
can't be fixed in seconds you didn't
have seconds you had three weeks the
universe was created in the third of
that time well someday you'll have to
tell us how you did it I'm begging you
to manage expectations out there you see
how this reminds you of a friendly face
it's warm and it's playful and inviting
and it needs to say hello if you keep
alienating people for no reason there'll
be no one left for it to say hello to
your Apple stock was worth 441 million
dollars well your daughter and her
mother are on welfare she's not my
daughter you must be able to see that
she looks like you you're issuing
contradictory instructions you're
insubordinate you make people miserable
okay even if that were true doesn't
sound that diabolical to me
we've spoken to the fire marshal in the
building manager they're gonna come in
and tell everyone to leave if a fire
causes a stampede to the unmarked exits
it'll have been well worth it for those
who survived the board believe you're no
longer necessary to this company i SAT
garage and invented the future because
artists lead and packs ask for a show of
hands